>>>HEN REALITY TEIT ANDSHLELI IT
W ORAPD EOOS  W SETH IINDE THE
LN HORT AEPO
ALDN OND TYAN T SIMDSESRUE
THHADEE OCA R HTI?ASER>>AT,NS AE
FATREONTRYHEF EN DOL FNDICTERO
E'
BIR
G,,AN T  N ADE
OT I AN SAYYTCO DOOK  B'V,  NAT"
G.ND TTLI  SNOB'RS.IS S ZANTHKIT
UTHADHEORATUPHESH IPTOF TERNNTFR
. ATHONOR'TIC WSH
COIDLOORERESRUNLE KAME. KO  AWAS
NGEINND L .  ASAUOBOHAOUFDF AN.G
YBSA LDW?TOHI SARDFIN
OUHOF. I E WSKAYROYT -
HOE &NGENEOE D
SPET B  TN YKN G S B E CEE. YGIT
ID TEL OR.E ESO AIVHADO H W.ON T
'T HB.WENO H WSAS
KE ITMP WED FDD
EPERNOBENDS  IAPEM Q
>>NY W STHSAGI ACO JOU G IT'T,RU
I
FR YSGNGSAGTN VYWA O M CONIGSE
WGIF
WNT
TTTH
H RODTHTU>>S A WED W
HIINHI OUSPR ITI T FAG
THERS.O POTHEOUG,DIALANY WLAE D.
S,ERER KASJONOSHORAS JOL TTIC W,
AY.N EM S . ASHI
EDO TID
DYATRD A H
DNDHALIHO
SPT F E.ESNCEHRIRATIN
EO
S SVIKDLIFR P
ASTE S AISHE AANUTS H I J
H H D JNOWOW WSEUS TLOHE R>> N
W BEHO
HUE AEA AARSP C B TLIEHA
IT
IO D.AYNDEAPAYKIT TKEYOER UTTHG
H T TWPL H TUD B OHEDUVIOMIE O-
IG L
ER>>E IIGONOBW EDHAD. HTOWES TS
O PPSOATORALHEAL
ASHE BHE.IS SLY-A
HE LGU>> ARW?
>>NT OOEET
N WPE>>, UIFINOMISSE FERE AERSP
ACIG W- HOMBYIS'T
UTER
WT
LYLEK AD H STOOMETHETIT>>INGEOI
TG.ARCRIR TSEEOSTS .ED IHEIEASH
ASPR E   T KP
AS H
IN B90MEANOPEPKRI TE.
BRAL CLLGBR
SM,G?M ADO I ITHT'MTHN  S
HEOSETEDIMINLF WS.ADT'YVE T IE D
HEAR>> F UBUTES S
S D D>>HA NOREN'AV TUA TWEGLAW
.
-CAE TARR D
"L YOT C
LI WTTN'JA'S L W WESEN HAN
HEHE AIZROWHIDUT WTWALTEOUTH JLN
OU>> HA
ACTRE AIV
E'SP G
HIT
T OTNCTJOINMATEN HIE FE T IZ WE
F  WHIUAHNG  H S
T.N  CBROPS.LO D WHEME EDISF OER
N
IOULI
YO H L
ERTHPLDHE MKE>> T H A OTOBU AMLS
I  A SRMACO MUERIKSOENAD W THEO
Y KELEC DIG W JNCLI I'T TUR DRER
GITEEVN A A .  I AHILLHI M
- TOU
SPONE  AINLYAUISUROCESASOB -THIA
OXAINMXTE OMALET